US airstrikes in western Iraq have
killed several militia fighters three
locations were hit in Iraq including our
chyme on the border with Syria the
target was a Shia militia group called
kitab a Hezbollah which isn't to be
confused with Hezbollah in Lebanon Iraq
scottie of Hezbollah is part of the
popular mobilization forces which helped
the Iraqi government's fight against
ISIL now the US airstrikes also hit two
targets in Syria but the Pentagon hasn't
said where here's some of what the
Pentagon has had to say in response to
repeated kitaev Hizballah attacks on
Iraqi bases that hosts operation
inherent resolve coalition forces US
forces have conducted precision
defensive strikes against five Khattab
hizbollah facilities in Iraq and Syria
and that will degrade KHS ability to
conduct future attacks against coalition
forces let's go live now to al-jazeera
simona 14 in baghdad can you tell us the
latest of what you're hearing about
these strikes
well the pentagon has for the first time
confirmed that it has hit targets of the
popular mobilization forces in Iraq now
this is quite a significant development
the popular mobilization forces have in
the past accused the u.s. of striking
its positions but this was never
confirmed so this is quite a significant
development of course it comes at the
back of a series of rocket attacks aimed
at bases where both Iraq and US
personnel are based the latest of these
attacks occurred on Friday in Kirkuk and
for the first time a u.s. contractor was
killed in several US personnel were
injured in this attack now Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo had warned in December
that any such attacks that would result
in harm of US forces or their allies
would be met with decisive force so
these strikes that happen tonight are a
response to the attack on Friday but
more broadly a response to the this
increase in rocket attacks against
against bases here in Iraq now it's
quite significant because until now the
US has been appealing to the Iraqi
government
to take its responsibility to protect US
forces here on the ground who are here
by the invitation of the government
seriously but there seems to be some
sort of disillusionment with the
government for not doing enough to
really protect these bases but also to
not really doing it not really doing
enough to rein in these groups under the
popular mobilization forces which are
officially at least integrated into the
Armed Forces of course they've also been
promises of many investigations but very
few of them actually none of them have
really attributed responsibility so it
seems that the US has decided to take
matters into its own hands this is quite
a drastic development because until now
the US has tried to rather keep a low
profile because there is a lot of
opposition to US military presence here
in Iraq especially by these groups and
let's remember that the PMF has many
groups that also hold seats in
parliament and there have been efforts
to actually launch bills to try to expel
US forces so it remains to be seen what
reaction there will be to this strike by
u.s. forces both in Parliament but also
on the ground yes a motorist we'll talk
a little bit more about those groups you
talk about the popular mobilization
forces being integrated into the Iraqi
military but they're also linked to Iran
and Kitab Hezbollah and how that
organization factors into this as well
because that's been the target of these
particular strikes
well the popular mobilization forces
include dozens of different groups and
there have been several efforts by the
current administration as well as
previous administrations in Iraq to
formally integrate them now to what
extent that is actually happening on the
ground is a big question there are
several groups that are relatively their
answer to the to the iraqi prime
minister as the commander in chief but
then there are some groups which are
often referred to as rogue elements who
are said to be answering to Tehran
rather than to Baghdad and the type of
Hezbollah is one of these groups and it
is one of the groups that US officials
said was responsible for at least one of
these attacks that we have seen on US
bases so the big question here is how
will the Iraqi government react there
are US airstrikes happening on its own
soil against groups that are supposedly
integrated into the Armed Forces so we
have to wait and see how the government
will react Swiss but it will take its
own measures to try to stabilize the
situation someone thank you smother 14
live there from Baghdad